in diesem heiklen moment meine damen und
herren wo es darum geht jedes versehen
zu vermeiden um nicht einen noch
größeren krieg auszulösen konnte diese
dramatische meldung vom krisenstab der
bundesregierung zwei
us35671d8570 irrt die bundespolizei
sichert ab bis us-kräfte eintreffen nach
bild-informationen waren beide us vom us
luftwaffenstützpunkt spangdahlem
gestartet wir sind live verbunden mit
dem sicherheitsexperten malte roschinsky
herr schelsky luft notlage was kann das
bedeuten in dieser situation
ja das kann ganz unterschiedliche
bedeutungen haben also zum beispiel kann
es sein dass kommunikationssysteme
ausgefallen sind dass es schwierigkeiten
gegeben hat mit der treibstoffversorgung
oder dass einige der elektronischen
systeme an bord viel funktioniert haben
also das kann das eben sein
informationen die wir auch relativ
schnell hier bekommen haben ist dass es
möglicherweise ist noch nicht bestätigt
einen notfall in die sendung eines
notfall codes gegeben haben soll 77 00
das aber zeitweise auch öffentlich
einsehbar und das ist ein not
kommunikations signal wenn andere
kommunikationskanäle nicht mehr
funktionieren da ist ist auch in der
zivilen luftfahrt
das alles hier in diesen heiklen
momenten ich habe es vorhin schon gesagt
das muss nicht unbedingt ein
zusammenhang bestehen trotzdem natürlich
sofort angst und sorge was sind das für
just diese f-35 die ja die modernsten
und teuersten kampfjets der welt sind
genau das sind ja das ist das modernste
was die us luftwaffe
auch zum beispiel die us marine und die
marineinfanterie in ihrem arsenal haben
an sozusagen luft systeme das
interessante an dem f-35 des hieß früher
joint strike fighter ist dass es ein
sehr
flexibles system ist das heißt zum einen
kann die er 35 als kampfflugzeug
eingesetzt werden um zum beispiel
bodenziele zu bekämpfen kann aber auch
dazu eingesetzt werden für den luft
luftkampf das heißt also auch um andere
kampfflugzeuge zur bekämpfung eine
lufthoheit in einem bestimmten luftraum
zu gewinnen aber und in dieser rolle
sind diese diese konkreten r35
offenkundig unterwegs es ist auch ein
system mit sehr vielen sensoren also mit
einer einer ganzen reihe von
elektronischen sensoren die alle
möglichen
kommunikation abhören können alle
möglichen signale aufnehmen und
verarbeiten können und insofern sind
diese f-35 die jetzt hier vermutlich
auch also dieser gelandet sind am ber
tatsächlich im einsatz gewesen für die
elektronische überwachung des luftraums
über
weißrussland also belarus und natürlich
eben auch in richtung ukraine also es
wären aber genau solche sätze wie sie
beispielsweise der ukrainische präsident
selen ski gefordert hat zur überwachung
einer flugverbotszone
ja gut diese forderung ist natürlich da
welche flugzeuge welche typen dafür dann
eigentlich in frage kommen das ist ganz
unterschiedlich die öffnung 30 käme dazu
in frage aber natürlich auch die elmex
flugzeuge ärzte 135 und andere typen von
überwachungsflugzeugen die f35 hier sind
jetzt für die nato in einer
unterstützungs rolle quasi im einsatz
also unterstützen die elektronische
aufklärung die sensorisch eben passiert
ein normaler weise gestützt durch andere
flugzeuge theoretisch wären das auch
flugzeuge mit dem man eine eine
sperrzone fahren sie auch einrichtungen
auch überwachen kann aber davon sind wir
politisch noch weit entfernt meinte
james key besten dank für diese
informationen nach dem 2 35 der us
airforce in berlin notlanden musste
besten dank